I had the craziest week teaching david
dobrik and johnson take the freeway
Melissa cheers to Wilson that's got into
my electric skateboard crash it's
located my shoulder and fractured in
between places in America they bring a
fire tractor come in handy overkill
they gave me these really strong pain
felt yeah and I came up with an idea
which took me to the desert in the
middle of South Africa you're gonna want
to stick around for this one
[Music]
okay after I released last week's poem
about collaboration with 100 filmmakers
from a hundred different countries I
received more than 15,000 emails which
literally broke my inbox and my brain I
needed what you call production support
problem is the only person that I trust
with the form of the scale is in South
Africa and it's my ex bus who fired me
so this is gonna take a lot more
convincing than a simple email I then
called up my mates at CBS all ethos is
about sharing experiences together and
they thought it was a pretty rad idea so
they decided to hook me up with this
mission if we click on the meter and the
app to enter my promo code brood and get
$20 off your first order now for about
ctq I'll get back to that now so I took
the first flight out of NYC back to Cape
Town where I've got an MRI scan and the
doctor told me this I can't see anything
here that means an operation yes yeah no
thank you no nothing to get an upper
haitian is pretty good news that means I
get to cruise around the streets of Cape
Town for the race of the day we're from
Cape Town to Jacek radioactive Airways
transmits from deep space
[Music]
and rocked up at my ex boss's office
[ __ ] you don't know the dynamic it
between Junaid and I so he has a quick
20-second explainer Junaid owns a
production house in Cape Town called
ground rods we are directed many TV
commercials including my first we
traveled the world together and became
really good friends but after time I
started becoming greedy and was showing
interest into bigger abs with more
budget and this song are not
satisfaction in making films with
meaning this led to me becoming more of
an expense than an asset so I got fired
and then joined a bigger production
house which was a pretty bad move
today's her birthday and I'm outside her
office to surprise it hello
no go stand outside actually she's gonna
see
[Music]
surprise I thought that was your voice I
heard what are you doing here for your
birthday no not today dan come on man
should we go inside yes sir
I'm actually not joking I'm somewhat
pissed off with you I just want to speak
oh no no and a camera no no just go to
the window over there
just gonna join sort this out okay I
can't wait in my office I'll come talk
to you five minutes luckily this wasn't
a big surprise I'm not even gonna show
you this this isn't going as I planned
but I'm gonna try and record this
conversation and just hope for the best
[Music]
Jeannette wanted to keep most parts of
this conversation confidential but I'll
sum it up for you she told me how pissed
off she was of need and what I wanted to
do was tell her my idea but it needed to
be a surprise so all I could offer her
was this blindfold which made her laugh
and she agreed to trust me one last time
I don't know if this is really but it
looks like we've got one foot in the
right direction then we made our way
down the highway and to the airport
where we met by meant our eerily flew us
over the Winelands through the snowy
mountains and dropped us off in the
middle of the desert
[Music]
she was silenced by this act because
where we had come from
and now to where we had returned
Jeanette and I met four years ago at a
temporary City of art expression music
and celebration called Africa burn in
the Klaine career yeah we spoke about
our dreams of working on a film that
would shift conversation and human
behavior we started working together
after this with good intentions but it
wasn't long after that I got swayed by
the politics within the traditional TV
advertising industry so I brought her
back here to apologize
[Music]
earlier that day I had sent up two tents
picked up some steampunk attire and
other funky [ __ ] organized a badass
beach buggy 4x4 a campfire and got her
son Max to pack a bag of a favorite
Africa burn wardrobe and some basic
essentials to recreate the first time we
admit and our very first conversation
about foam we had 24 hours to escape
with no politics
[Music]
the series is about friendship the
global expression grew a term of
endearment that means the same thing in
every language not just a friendship
society gently forces you into new
school work age dynamic or six rude to
me means unconventional eccentric and
free-spirited frame
[Music]
I'm on this mission to find the Bruce
and me I took this time to explain my
project to see if should give me a
chance to work together again as friends
this time with no manual just pure art
[Music]
to sum up Jeanette's and my chat last
night before the fire dad was too cold
her answer to my question if she wants
to be involved in this project went
something like this
dan I forgive you okay that was very
scripted but we making a movie I've two
really exciting in the Huntsman's first
is we have merged I'm not lying
we have brew merge there's only a
limited amount of these I'll put the
link in the description these are gonna
be the first generation of this brew
merge they made out of 100% recycled
cotton pretty sure this is the first
merch that's done this I'm working with
some of the best in the business in
order to make sure that we remain
sustainable so go click on the link and
audios now and - I didn't have to do
this I could have just put in the
description but I really love it when
brands get it right and Cee Grady helped
me out by getting Jeanette's and my
friendship back together and getting P
to South Africa so here goes for one
massive pant see peak is an app that
aggregates tickets from all over the web
to make behind simple
they put a 1 to 100 score and each
ticket to know if you're getting a good
deal or a bad one
there's absolutely no reception out here
in the desert but I'll cut to another
screen of me
scrolling through this app view from
seat lets you see where you're gonna sit
and if you click on the me tab and the
app to enter my promo code blue and get
$20 off your first order you can
download the app by clicking on the link
in the description I'll put it on the
top line as well as if you are keen for
merch I'll also link that in the
description below seed geek and as
always remember your awesome brew
and I'll see you next week Wednesday
[Music]
[Music]